(drums beating)
(crowd applauding)
(speaking in Japanese)
(mysterious music)
(newspaper pages rustling)
(speaking in Japanese)
(upbeat piano music and
singing in Japanese)
(upbeat jazz music)
(speaking in Japanese)
(peaceful piano music
and singing in Japanese)
(audience applauding)
(chanting)
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
(chanting and cheering)
(speaking in Japanese)
(announcer talking over speakers)
(crowd applauding)
(speaking in Japanese)
(drums beating)
(yelling and applauding)
(yelling)
(singing in Japanese)
(cheering and yelling)
(clapping)
(drums beating)
(cheering)
(cheering and applauding)
(somber music)
- [Cameraman] One, two, three.
(somber piano music)